welcome everyone thank you for joining
us at the tissue-based research
workflows virtual event our next
presentation for today is selecting the
right detection for your IHC ish project
fluorescence versus chromiogenic
staining presented by Sheena Washington
my name is Serena and I'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is Interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation
to ask a question click on the Q a box
located on the bottom of your screen
type your questions and hit submit the
speaker will answer your question
following the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the Q a
box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
please join me by welcoming Sheena for
complete biography on our speaker visit
the biography tab on the left Sheena
over to you
hello and welcome to the Leica
biosystems presentation on why quality
matters and my little segment on
selecting the right detection method for
your IHC and ish assays
so my name is Sheena Washington and I am
a senior field application specialist in
advanced standing for life science with
by like a bio systems I've been with
Leica for five and a half years previous
to that I worked in research Histology
for approximately 17 years doing IHC I
have standard staining microscopy
fluorescent microscopy confocal
microscopy all kinds of different things
for both human and animal tissues and
I've worked in Academia and cros and now
in the commercial industry
a little bit about me
so I want to clarify before we get into
the the meat of this presentation that
the presentation does assume some basic
knowledge of IHC and ish Concepts uh
it's
uh basically antibodies antigens probes
RNA DNA relationships heat and enzyme
antigen retrievals antibody titrations
dilutions things like that so to gain
the most from this information covered
in this presentation you will need some
prior background and experience with IHC
so we will jump into it here
so
summary of this is how to select the
most appropriate detection method for
your work so some initial considerations
um we'll talk about first
chromogenic versus fluorescent labeling
we'll move into single versus Multiplex
labeling which everybody gets very
excited about and available Technologies
and finally some best practice
[Music]
so choosing the appropriate detection
method for your targets will allow
researchers to produce the most
compelling visual images to support
their research goals we'll discuss some
of the major factors that contribute to
effective single and Multiplex standings
with focus of course on quality
um and then we'll talk about some best
practices for assay development
so talking about initial considerations
these are going to be some some key
Concepts you want to think about before
you even before you purchase anything
before you spend any money
um so what are the research questions
that I need to answer first and foremost
that's what you need to be thinking
about
the desired endpoint typically
determines what kind of detection method
will work best for you so ask yourself
what is it that you really need to
demonstrate you know there are lots of
fun things out there and maybe a fun
idea to put 20 markers on the same piece
of tissue but do you really need that
and in the end are you going to be able
to analyze that effectively
uh next uh good good question is to know
what's already your lab that you have at
your disposal so what kind of
microscopes do you have access to what
kind of reagents do you already have
in-house
um that leads directly into the next the
next question of how much time and how
much money do I have so what uh what is
your budget for the project can you
afford to try something new
what is the timeline for the project and
do we have time to develop something
completely new those are big
considerations you don't want to wish
most people don't want to waste a lot of
time and money
the next one is who will actually be
doing the work so do we have the
manpower to develop a new assay do we
have personnel with the skill and
experience to develop that essay so
those are some big considerations too
um
that leads into how will you analyze the
data do you have the right analysis
methods for the type of detection method
that you are selecting so if you have
obviously if you've only got light
microscopes in house a fluorescent
detection assay is probably going to be
pretty pricey because you will also have
to find a fluorescent microscope to use
somewhere or buy a whole new one with
all the different filters and different
things that go along with that too so if
you've only got like my Crest micro
microscopy in-house you may want to go
with a bright Fields chromogenic
detection assay
so do you
um how who will analyze the data so
that's always fun to know like will it
be student helpers doing the analysis of
the the data will it be a pathologist
doing the analysis of the data so
knowing who these these final slides um
are going to to be read and analyzed
um will be key in in making it useful as
well
so
um another big consideration is what
kind of support do you have access to so
do we have access to resources to
support our potential knowledge gaps do
we have access to resources to assist
with any issues that may arise with
developing the assay or analyzing the
assay the outcome of the slides
so those are some really important
things to think of before you even get
started with purchasing the newest
latest and greatest funnest detection
methods out there on the market right
now
so now we'll get into the differences
between
um the main two main detections we're
going to talk about today so the
chromogenic staining
so chromogenic
um
detection assays
they
first and foremost are
the predominant detection technology in
clinical settings and primarily it's
it's just like what we're looking at
right here in this photo that the dab di
Amino Benzene substrate with its
familiar brown color
so this is still widely used in research
as chemistry as well for assay
development improved concept nothing
else
the nice thing about this you know like
I said it's widely accepted so
acceptance is the number one
top benefit of this people know how to
read the ab stains it's widely accepted
they know what they're looking at
second is the cost it's relatively
inexpected inexpensive detection option
um
there are many different options out
there so availability is another
there's a range of different enzymatic
detection
um commercial vendors commonly use the
dab test to demonstrate their IHC
products and antibodies
so lots of options out there highly
available
microscopy it is a highly accessible
detection technology as it can be
visualized by using standard bright
field light microscopes which most Labs
already have available to them
uh so the range of substrates and
chromogene colors um that's also a
benefit uh the dab substrate works with
uh horseradish peroxidase enzyme which
is a robust enzyme now has several color
substrates other than the standard dab
you can do yellows and blues and greens
and purples and reds
um
there are also a couple of other enzyme
options for detection the one we see
most often is the AP the alkaline
phosphatase enzyme the AP and detection
also offers a range of different color
substrates red Blues greens Etc
all right
so fluorescent detection is
is not as widely used and accepted as
the chromogenic detection methods it has
been growing in popularity and we do see
it quite often in research and there are
just as many fluorescent detection
reagents and options out there
but most of the time we see people
choosing fluorescent detection out of
necessity because
um
the options for direct labeling
um is is one major reason this can be
fast and efficient for optim or
optimizing and neutralizing certain
markers direct detection often requires
less development and skill to produce
high quality results so if you've got if
you've got less experience people
working in the lab this may be a good
option for you to take so alternatively
you know indirect labeling is another
method you can use both for chromogenic
and fluorescent detection but
alternatively you know it gives you
introduces more variables but it also
provides a bit more flexibility in the
sense that you can use the same
primaries or probes with different
colors
so you can mix and match a bit more but
direct labeling is a is a nice option
there with the fluorescence
the most common reason we see groups
choosing fluorescence in in research
right now is
um because they are looking for multiple
markers that co-lobalize and by
co-localize I mean they present in the
same cell or the same cellular
compartment and when chromogens overlap
it can be very difficult to visualize
and analyze the staining results so and
this is not really an issue for
fluorescent labeling so as long as you
are choosing fluorophores that are far
enough apart on the emission spectrum
you can easily visualize and distinguish
between different targets on the same
cells with fluorescent detection
uh fluorescent detection Technologies
also offer the ability to detect more
Targets on the same sample so like I
said if you've got co-localizing things
you don't have to worry about them
overlapping
so we very often will see you know seven
or more targets being labeled on the
same
but all of them overlapping uh mind you
it's very it's still quite a challenge
to try to see seven Targets overlapped
in the same space but you can get
seven and Beyond Targets on the same
tissue sample on the same slide so that
has become a very huge benefit of
fluorescent detection
recent advancements in Imaging
Technologies have made visualization of
both chromogenic and fluorescent much
easier than it used to be so they're not
it's not always a huge concern but it's
something to keep in mind
multiplexing consideration so if you are
looking to detect more than one marker
on the same piece of tissue
so I've got a couple colorful photos
there demonstrations of multiplexing
so any kind of multiplexing assay
requires a solid comprehension of the
basics of basic IBC basic ish and
automated platform if you are using one
so if you're using an automated stainer
you need to have a solid
solid comprehension of its function as
well what it's capable of doing or not
so with any Multiplex Staffing there are
many variables that can require
intensive development work so
tissue-based multiplexing assays can be
comp as complicated as they look here so
you look at this and it's a little
boggling to the the eye and it can be
just as complicated to try to get a a
beautiful outcome like this there are
many variables to consider so it's
important to start with those
fundamentals
[Music]
um
primary antibody compatibility
is a is a primary concern
then we've got optimizing your antibody
or probe titration optimizing your
pre-treatment conditions chromogenic and
fluorophore efficiency changes in Signal
through subsequent processing
so we will take those one at a time here
so primary antibody primary probe
compatibility so these things primary
antibody quality and when I say quality
I'm talking about things like Affinity
which means the specific specificity for
a particular antigen
ability is another concept so strength
of The Binding to the Target and then
prevalence within the tissue
so those are some things to keep in mind
when we're talking about antibody
quality
lots of lots of choices out there
commercially available as far as
antibodies can be challenges when we've
got antibodies that are generated
in-house but quality is certainly a big
concern
species is another concern so the the
host species for your your primary
um
mostly we think about cross-reactivity
which can occur when antibodies from the
same host species are being put onto the
same tissue
uh and then the other thing we worry
about is Cellular location
um where we can have issues of steric
hindrance or just hindrance of binding
due to the previous antibody that's been
placed on
um or even just obstructive deposits
left by substrates especially if you're
working with chromogens
so those are some concerns with your
primaries depending on the technology
you choose you know this may or may not
have a major factor be a major factor
and have a major impact on your assay
development some technologies are are
made to be species agnostic and ish
protes can be very specific to sequence
so the success of other detection
methods may depend heavily on
compatibility of antibodies and targets
you know clones or sequences but some
things
um will will definitely
be species agnostic so that's just a
couple considerations with your your
primaries
next thing
optimizing your antibodies and probe
concentrations so
this um this is key certainly if you are
going to like I said earlier try to
throw you know 20 markers at a piece of
tissue at the same time you're going to
need to know the optimized dilution
concentration of those primaries
um and the probes as well so people
often attempt you know right out of the
box to throw all of the desired markers
onto a piece of tissue at once which can
provide some baseline information but
rarely produces the desired quality of
outcome so optimizing the individual
antibodies of probes prior to combining
them will provide a good sound Baseline
for understanding the expected
performance of each marker
and it will Aid in the decision-making
process for tweaks that maybe need may
need to be made later
um in the assay process assay building
process so once the markers are combined
optimizing pre-treatment conditions so
once you've got your your optimal you're
working out your optimized titration for
your antibodies or probes you will also
want to work out your optimized
conditions for pre-treatment so each
marker in a multiplexed assay may
require a different pre-treatment to
produce the best quality staining
results on its own so whether this is
higher the heat episode retrieval or
enzymatic retrieval it'll be crucial to
determine this for each marker
so in order to determine the retrieval
conditions necessary to incorporate into
the multiplex assay
chromogen and fluorophore efficiency so
reagent solution stability is the first
thing I think of when I when I talk
about efficiency so refers to the
general performance of qualities of the
chromogenic substrates or the
fluorescent dyes some color substrates
or floors may be much more robust than
others so for chromogens when we look at
stability in terms of the region itself
so once Solutions are mixed uh we we can
see precipitates it may be sensitive to
Tire to temperature or light
um and
whether the label deposit that that you
get from the final product can hold up
to to high temperature to changes in PH
uh to salinity changes
um and whether it is solvent resistant
in the end so once you are actually
you've actually got the slide stained
and you are going to mount them
permanently or with aqueous mounting
medium some
different chromogens they may they may
vary in the mounting needs
so
fluorophores we may have some that are
always much stronger than others and
when we see a loss of signal due to
photo bleaching over time that's that's
the primary consideration with the
floors
potential changes in Signal through
processing so as we are going through
multiplexing and different rounds of
different solutions going on to the
piece of tissue onto a slide are we
seeing changes with subsequent
subsequent rounds so
we we only really need to consider this
most of the time with sequential assays
so if you are doing a parallel
multiplexing assay this is not going to
be such a huge concern
um changes to staining over the course
of subsequent processing with heat with
different pH Solutions
um different salidities
um can really change the the end of
staining so this is this common with
sequential but a bit less with parallel
the effect makes determining the optimal
order of application for your markers
and their Associated standing conditions
so epitope retrieval stripping methods
makes it crucial to the the quality of
the spinal standing result
so chromogenic multiplexing stains
here's here's a little example um this
comes from my own portfolio and my own
experience I I couldn't couldn't tell
you what the exactly what the the
markers are anymore I can't I can't
remember and did not have it labeled on
the photo so
um
but I know that this is a CD marker
you've got a
probably a fox speaker or t-bed and
um
a Ki 67 I believe at the time or Bond RX
so
this took let me think this took me
probably a few months in in development
and
these markers this is on a human tonsil
so this was just uh just my test run
here
um
the image was also produced in a like a
micro like a light microscope so
considerations here were the limitations
of the automated platform at the time
um is it capable of doing Multiplex
chromogenic write-off does it have
features that lend itself to that uh
solution stability was a huge issue here
so you kind of see that that blue green
color that chromogen was not stable over
time it had a life once mixed once it
was mixed it was it was labile and it
would start to precipitate out of
solution after about 15 minutes
so we had to keep that in mind
Cellular location so you can see here
that the the brown color is very
ubiquitous
um all over the place in there so we
wanted to put that one on first the dab
was a more stable chromogen and held up
better through subsequent subsequent
rounds of staining so we put that dab
brown color on and it did take some some
balancing so we did have to back off on
concentration to get it to be that nice
light brown so that you could get the
the red color to kind of show through it
and same thing with the the blue green
so we wanted to balance colors so that
took some some tweaking of the antibody
concentrations and the epitope retrieval
conditions
um determining cross reactivity it's
always nice to be able to do some
testing
um with your chromogens and stuff so
you'll do them work them up one at a
time and then you'll work them up in
combination and there are some tests you
can do to determine whether you're
getting cross reactivity or getting a
real signal with multiple markers
and then visual contrast compatibility
you can kind of see by looking at this
that the brown and the red are very
close in the color of family so can be
tough to distinguish red from Brown and
especially if red and brown are on the
same cell if they're co-lobalized can be
very tough to see this
whereas the the blue green has a nice
strong contrast against those colors so
now to keep that in mind as well and
then order of staining um kind of
discussed that already where uh we put
out decided to put on the the CD marker
uh the very ubiquitous Brown uh first
because it held up better through
subsequent rounds of staining
um I think I believe then the red went
on and then we had the the blue green in
the end
so moving on to a fluorescent Multiplex
so this I believe is exactly the same
assay exactly the same markers on a
human tonsil but this was done with
fluorescent detection reagents so
um I developed the IHC assay first and
then I've tried to move it into a
multiplex immunofluorescent assay and
that really sped up the process having
having the whole thing worked out in
chromogens first and there were some
some processes involves excuse me that
were quicker with the is the chromogenic
development was not a consideration so
some things went a little more smoothly
but in in the entirety of the
development it still took about a month
to transition to this this if assay from
the original IHC assay
um
the microscopy and imaging was a
challenge at the time all we had in the
lab that could do the fluorescent
um the analysis and detection was um
was a confocal microscope so it was a
Leica confocal
um and then the biggest challenge for me
at the time was that we in the lab did
not have a good way of analyzing this
data so we did not have software in the
lab that we could use to to separate out
all and do cell counts for us or
anything like that so after months and
months and months of doing all these
multiple Multiplex detection work both
the chromogenic and the fluorescent it
sat on a shelf and and wasn't able to be
read right away because we did not have
the analysis
in-house
so available Technologies there are lots
of things out there when we talk about
enzymes we talked about the the
prevalence of the the hrp the
horseradish peroxidase enzyme and then
the alkaline phosphatase enzyme we see
those pretty regularly there's a beta
gal the beta galact galactosidase
um that one is is a little bit more
obscure
amplification so a lot of people want to
see nice dark or nice bright staining of
their markers so they like to try to
amplify the signal
polymers oligos TSA happens lots of
stuff out there on the market
um
so
break apart Technologies are another new
thing that are allowing spatial
relations and quantification so
um there are different Technologies out
for that as well and then service Labs
can be a really great option for those
who do not have the resources to develop
their own assays in-house there are lots
of lots of groups out there now who will
do
sustaining as a service and as well as
the analysis as a service
so as far as best practices go early
inventory of needs and resources is
crucial
always good to take take stock of what
you have at your disposal and then a
good hard look at what you actually need
review of reagent specifications
make sure that you know
what you need for to work with your
reagents so know the stability of your
reagents know what they are compatible
with and not compatible with
and once you know that go back and take
stock of what you already have and what
you don't have and what you may need
specifically a specific example of that
would be
chromogen substrate so some of the
substrates are not solvent stable or
solvent proof they will dissolve in
different different organic solvents so
you can't run them down the way you
normally would just a dab sting or
something like that they may you may and
get some products in the end with
absolutely no staining on them because
it dissolved into your mounting media
um
automated platform compatibility so
there are lots of automated platforms
out there right now
um
they have different capabilities
different different Specialties pros and
cons about all of them
um a lot of people
will decide they want to do something
and then find out that their their
instrument actually cannot do that fully
automated or cannot do it at all so it's
good to know the actual limitations of
your your automated platform if that's
the route you're going to go or that you
need to go
uh and then the final one absolutely
hands down being diligent development so
optimizing things one thing at a time
good scientific method and adjustment of
you know just one variable at a time as
you're going along will produce the best
quality outcome
so uh just some
and just some some good references here
um something that some an author that
really helped me uh when I was going
after information on this and doing it
myself in the laboratory
um Chris vanderloose so a couple
different Publications here of his and
that will end my presentation and I
would like to thank my uh life science
applications team and my mentors
and thank you we'll take some time for
some questions
well thank you so much Sheena for that
informative presentation just
a reminder to our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the Q a
we will answer many questions as we have
time for
and the first question is
how do you know if the chromogens you
want to use in a chromogenic multiplex
are compatible
so chromogenes are very dependent on the
vendor that they come from right so it's
very important when you're choosing
chromogens to check the the data sheet
and the instructions for use to know
what solutions they may or may not be
compatible with to check whether they
are solvent stable so whether you are
going to be able to cover split them the
way you normally cover split things in
your in your laboratory
so check the data sheets before you go
picking out and ordering certain things
because very often different chromogens
may or may not be compatible so
uh specifically look for solvent
stability so can you run them through
graded alcohols can you run them through
xylene and then check whether there is
any listing of the kind of mounting
media they are compatible with so are
they are you able to use permanent
mountains that contains xylene or
toluene or things like that or are they
going to require aqueous mounting media
and if they are not compatible if you've
got two one that requires aqueous
mounting and one that requires permanent
mounting you may end up with only you
know one color on your on your slides in
the end so very important to check the
data sheets and the instructions for use
on your on your Chrome engines
very good it looks like we have one more
um unless more come in the second
question is how do you know whether your
automated platform is suitable to
perform the kind of detection you've
chosen
automated platforms can vary a lot so
that's very important again I I talked a
little bit about this in the
presentation
about knowing the functionality knowing
the limitations of your automated system
so things like is it able to mix
Solutions so most of the chromogens that
you that you order come as component
parts so they're modular they come with
you know one two or more solutions that
you're going to need to mix together to
apply to get the the substrate that you
need on on the slack so can your
instrument actually do that or is that
something you're going to have to do
offline is that something you're going
to have to do by hand
um so can keep that in mind another
thing would be checking the protocol so
if you have a protocol that you've
gotten from from literature or that is
listed with the technology that you that
you are considering make sure that your
instrument is capable of of doing the
things that are needed in that protocol
so is it going to require heat heat is a
big one
um can your instrument Heat
within the pro the protocol that you are
trying to to use
so I would say those are the two biggest
concerns
um mixing of solutions is your is your
instrument capable of mixing Solutions
and also heat being included in the
assay that you're running
is it able to heat yeah
fantastic well thank you again Sheena
and thank you to our audience for
joining us today and they're interesting
questions we will address any questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during our on-demand period
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this session
webcast will be available on demand
after this
thanks for the session and thanks for
joining us thank you for now